today on the Matt wall show Kanye West
has a psychotic episode on camera and
it's very sad to watch actually also an
official at Buckingham Palace is forced
to resign because she asks a black woman
where she's from it's the dumbest racism
controversy all year and that's really
saying something plus a new hit piece
accuses Ron DeSantis of not being fun to
which I say well good and a court case
in France is a huge win for the world's
most marginalized group and by that I
mean introverts we'll talk about all
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
distracted by parties and presents this
holiday season instead join Hallows most
anticipated prayer challenge of the Year
pray 25 led by cast members from The
Chosen the largest Christian treatment
service in history streaming Series in
history I should say pray 25 will guide
you through meditation and prayer for 25
days leading up to Christmas pray 25
will help grow your understanding of
mankind to develop a disciplined prayer
habit during a season when discipline is
put to the test hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S and the
number one Catholic app in the world
hallow helps me make prayer a priority
and with pray 25 it can do the same for
you find peace and fortify your faith
this Christmas with Christmas with
hallow download the app for free and
join the pray 25 challenge go to
hello.com Matt Walsh and get three
months completely free that's hello.com
Matt Walsh to reclaim your piece during
this holiday season
well I have not spent uh very much time
talking about Kanye West on this show
and that's partly because I figure
you're getting quite enough Kanye
content from every other podcast in the
world it's also because
a celebrity going around and saying
outlandish things is not the kind of
story that I find terribly interesting I
think there are much more important
things happening in the world and I try
to focus on those but yesterday's events
do I think call for some uh commentary
now that the man has fully completed the
process of his own self-destruction
there are some things that uh I think we
can learn crucial takeaways and I would
like to spend
a little bit of time talking about them
so as you've no doubt already heard
Kanye appeared on Alex Jones's show
yesterday afternoon the interview is the
Capstone on a week that began with the
rapper storming out of Tim Poole's
podcast after Tim offered gentle
pushback to Kanye's ideas
he did not storm out on Alex Jones
however though perhaps considering what
he said it would have been better for
him if he had again and again throughout
the interview West wearing a ski mask
completely covering his face for the
entire conversation
insisted on a point that he felt like it
was it was very important to make uh he
wanted to make it clear
that he thinks Hitler and the Nazis get
a bad rap and here he is introducing
that idea
that's right you're not Hitler you're
not a Nazi you don't deserve to be
called that and demonized well
I I see I I see good things about Hitler
also the Jew I love everyone and Jewish
people are not going to tell me you can
love
um you know us and you can love what
we're doing to you with the contracts
and you can love what we're you know
what we're pushing with the pornography
but this guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table especially
Hitler
especially Hitler
and somehow that was not the craziest
moment of the show later Kanye launched
into some sort of puppet act making fun
of Benjamin not Netanyahu and using a
bottle of Yoo-hoo and a net as puppets
and it took me a while to figure that
one out because I'm not you know I
usually I'm good with the with the puns
but net and Yahoo okay
um it's hard to make heads or tails out
of this but here it is I was tired of
picking up the Yahoo and The netting so
finale's just netting I know some people
call him BB no some of you call them
yeah yeah but we're gonna call him
Nathan
what you want then hey yay right after
this I'm gonna say you're crazy I'm
gonna take your family away from you
we're not done with you yet you cannot
cause free thought we have to control
the history books we have to control the
banks and we have to go and kill people
also we're in a better area
so
and in a little longer hopefully you're
gonna take the mask off because this is
this actually Yay here
right okay then and he also returned to
his Hitler Fanboy routine like I said
several times but um perhaps most
notably with uh with this
I like Hitler I don't like Hitler
trying to be shocking with that I'm not
trying to be shocking I like Hitler I do
not I the the Holocaust is not what
happened let's look at the facts of that
and Hitler has a lot of redeeming
quality
so he said those exact words I like
Hitler multiple times at other points in
the show he also said that we need to
stop dissing the Nazis doesn't want to
diss them he said he doesn't like
describing Nazis as evil
and then Kanye went home and hopped on
Twitter where he tweeted an image of a
star of David combined with a swastika
and he also tweeted multiple times in
support of uh Balenciaga claiming that
God loves the company and then saying
this quote I stand by Balenciaga and
denounce all witch hunts and I cancel
cancel culture Jesus is King ending
trafficking doesn't start or end with a
fashion campaign for Christ's sake
well no Kanye we should absolutely
cancel companies that put out BDSM ads
featuring children they should be
canceled condemned boycotted I'm against
witch hunts too unless there's an actual
witch to hunt
but I suppose Kanye had already defended
Hitler so why not child pornographers
while he's at it eventually Elon Musk
suspended Kanye from Twitter what
appears to be as far as I could tell a
temporary 12-hour suspension ostensibly
because of the swastika image which Elon
said
is uh in an example of inciting violence
which is absurd obviously you either
believe in free speech or you don't Elon
is running the platform as a free speech
platform or he isn't you know it's one
of the other he said in the past that
people are free to post what they want
as long as they aren't directly calling
for violence against another individual
or group well
Kanye did not directly call for violence
what he posted and what he said to Alex
Jones
can certainly be described as
objectionable insane outrageous immoral
along with many other similar adjectives
but free speech means you're free to say
objectionable insane outrageous immoral
things
of course now there's there's an
argument you could make and I've seen
some people make this argument that
maybe Elon suspended Kanye for his own
good kind of like a a mercy killing
approach on social media just to get him
to cool down stop talking put down the
shovel that he was using to bury himself
and since Elon owns the platform he has
every right to make that call if he
wants to but if that's what Twitter is
now if Twitter is a kingdom and Elon is
the king and he gets to make the rules
as he goes along arbitrary as they may
be then then he should say that now
again his every right to run it that way
it is his platform he bought at fair and
square but he should say so for the sake
of honesty and transparency what he's
actually said is that there will be free
speech
and if that's what he's claiming he
should follow through on that even in
these hard case situations now as for
the rest of the story first of all
it should go without saying
I would certainly hope that it does
but just to be clear about this
um Hitler was a degenerate Mass
murdering lunatic so if you're gonna put
your own credibility on the line and
your reputation and your name and your
career and everything to defend someone
or to point out their redeeming
qualities quote unquote it shouldn't be
for the sake of one of History's
Greatest monsters and not incidentally
Hitler was also a man who by the way
would have thrown Kanye himself into the
gas chamber without hesitation Kanye is
rallying to the fence of a man and of a
group that would have considered him
sub-human because of his race
so this is pure self-loathing
self-immolating Madness
and on that point second
it's hard not to laugh about some of
this because it's so awkward and weird
and that's just the natural response
when you see something awkward and weird
but in in truth you know it's it's
actually not funny this man is having a
mental breakdown he's losing his mind he
is sick he is not well
he is in very bad shape
nothing could be more clear
and yet he has no one in his life
apparently who cares about him or loves
him because there's no one talking any
sense to him he surrounded himself with
vultures and parasites who have leeched
onto him and are feeding off of his
notoriety and encouraging him to plunge
even deeper into Insanity for their own
benefit
it is it is a pitiful spectacle to
behold
Kanye West was was truly once an
artistic genius and an important
cultural Voice once
but now he's eating himself alive on
camera
to the Delights of the gawking crowd
Kanye has built a bonfire and thrown
himself into it
if there was ever anyone in his life who
was willing to pull him away from the
Flames he's obviously cut them out at
this point leaving only the enablers and
the coattail Riders and now he is
hopelessly and helplessly spiraling into
the abyss and that's what we're watching
this is not an excuse for Kanye it's
simply an observation it gets very clear
the guy's just not well
and the fact is that Fame can drive
anyone into madness I mean once you
reach a certain level of Fame you're
living something that can barely be
described as a human existence you
become especially these days a product a
brand an entity
you're no longer viewed as a person but
but uh but you are viewed you're not
viewed as a person but you are viewed by
everyone all the time
you are you are on display all the time
you have none of the anonymity that
normal people take for granted no
privacy no ability to ever be just sort
of a face in the crowd and when you're
at Kanye's level
you're so famous that the people around
you can become famous second hand right
and so you find yourself surrounded by
self-interested Fame [ __ ] who
continually push you into the spotlight
so that they can have a piece of it for
themselves
and if you're already prone to
eccentricity as all artists are this
kind of uh this kind of Life can quite
easily destroy you which is why through
history we have seen
now the the self-destruction takes many
forms this is a rather unique form
but um certainly you know more common
things like artists you know succumbing
to drug abuse alcoholism suicide you
know those sorts of things again this is
not an excuse for Kanye it's just it's
an attempt at an explanation as to what
we're seeing here
third Point perhaps most importantly
I would hope
that Kanye West's psychotic break which
is what this is
would be enough to finally dissuade
conservatives from falling madly in love
with any celebrity who says one thing
they agree with
you know Kanye West was
talking about this thing or that thing
kind of babbling and over the years and
he's made one or two comments that
conservatives liked and suddenly he was
a conservative hero
so on the right we've we've been
desperate for celebrity approval and
celebrity endorsement for so long and
it's like it's pathetic
and it's given rise to this unfortunate
habit of launching in latching onto any
famous person who ever so mildly or
tentatively affirms our position on any
topic
I would hope that this would be enough
to break that celebrity fawning spell
there's nothing there's nothing wrong
with agreeing with a celebrity or even
congratulating them when they take a
stand on an issue
like you know a month ago or a month and
a half ago which feels like a million
years now but um
when he uh came out and and and spoke up
for The Unborn
there's nothing wrong at the time as I
did saying that's that's the correct
view I'm glad he said that
so there's there's that that's one thing
but what we shouldn't be doing is making
them into a standard Bearer a hero a
champion of the cause
yeah we shouldn't be doing that
automatically just because they're
famous
especially by the way you know one one
thing is like
somebody is famous and then they come
along out of nowhere and they say one
can serve one quote conservative thing
and
and then they become they you know they
they get put on this pedestal and it's
like they along with all the other
reasons why that's a problem to respond
that way it's also they haven't earned
it you know they haven't been in the
cause fighting for this they haven't
done anything for it
they just happen to say one thing
and in many cases these are people who
up to that point had been contributing
to the cultural rot
and they say one thing and it's just
it's an unearned position
which means that you also can't trust
the person
like they're going to disappoint you
and if I was optimistic I would say that
maybe the right will be smarter about
this kind of thing from now on but I'm
not optimistic
in fact some on the right seem to have
decided that they've boarded the Kanye
[ __ ] but now have to go down with it
which is which is really which is also
sad that's that's the you know that's
the word of the day here sad
because you don't need to
if you defended him in the past and you
were on the Kanye thing and you know and
it's okay to say now this guy's got
problems and then just move on with your
life you can do that
I've seen some defending him even still
looking for excuses coming up with all
these outlandish copes and
rationalizations claiming for example
that Kanye's pro-hitler stuff was just
him advocating for radical Christian
love love thy enemy they say but that's
not what Kanye said he made it clear
explicitly he likes Hitler he didn't say
love he said I like him like
okay the Bible does not call us to like
everyone
much less Mass murdering lunatics
you said you think it says he has a lot
of redeeming qualities a lot
he said we shouldn't diss the Nazis now
that's not loving thy enemy that's just
insane is what that is
it's also we should note
a really big favor to the left
okay who benefits from all this
well I mean they benefit from it in fact
if I was going to come up with some
conspiracy theory to explain Kanye's
pro-hitler pivot I would say that he's a
leftist on a Kamikaze mission to
embarrass and discredit as many
conservatives as possible now I don't
think that okay that's not the theory
that I hold I think he's simply mentally
ill as I've already covered but that's
the only conspiracy theory that even
would begin to make sense if you're
looking for one
because the left is the only beneficiary
here that's why they're so gleeful about
Kanye's plunge into madness they're not
upset about it they don't think it's sad
they can't get enough of it they love it
they they want him to be trending with
all this crazy stuff they love every
minute of it why wouldn't they why
wouldn't they love it I mean some of
their ideological opponents hitched
their wagon to Kanye and then Kanye
proceeded to drive right off a cliff
with those people attached which is a
which is a very fortunate turn of events
for the left
but not for anyone else
and especially not for Kanye himself who
is a troubled man who needs help
not attention
which is why now that I've said my piece
I will go back to what I was doing
before
and not give it to him
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
it was a show before Christmas and
through the studio
no other host was stirring not even
Shapiro
while the merch was set on the shelves
with care
in hopes that Sweet Daddy soon would be
there
[Music]
the sweet babies were nestled all snug
in their beds
while visions of walruses danced in
their heads
then over on Twitter there arose such a
clatter
I was trending on the timeline for some
erroneous matter
but I ignored it like every other time
shrugging off the satanic unhinged blue
hair slime
then my merch making elves created a
collectible new batch adding to my
coveted program the sweet Santa Baby
patch
they'll sell out from my store so don't
wait don't stop just head on over to
dailywire.com shop
you know I've revealed to you many times
that I struggle with uh nausea
especially when when I'm in the back of
a car taking an Uber or something like
that and the way they drive those cars
is certainly doesn't help my case at all
but as you know I've solved that problem
with relief band relief band is the
number one FDA cleared anti-nausea
wristband clinically proven to quickly
and effectively prevent or relieve
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness and
chemotherapy whether you need everyday
nausea relief or an occasional cure
relief band's patented technology makes
feeling sick a thing of the past like
the name says relief band is
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea
that's why they call it relief band you
can even change the intensity depending
on how you happen to be feeling relief
band has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau and over 100 000
satisfied customers so if you want the
band that actually works to relieve your
nausea check out relief band I've worked
out an exclusive offer just for my
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code Welsh you'll get 20 off
plus free shipping and a no questions
asked
30-day money-back guarantee so go to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use promo code
Walsh for 20 off plus free shipping
well here's a story that's gotten a lot
of attention especially over on the pond
uh over over the pond not on the pond
over the pond yeah that's what I'm
trying to say across the ocean
um reading from the daily wires report
is what says a Buckingham Palace
official has resigned resigned after she
allegedly asked a black guest where she
really came from the late Queen
Elizabeth's
um lady in waiting Susan Hussey made the
remarks during an event that took place
at Buckingham Palace on Tuesday per the
BBC the publication noted that she asked
the background question of Charity
founder in gozi Fulani Fulani said that
she was totally stunned by huzzy's
comments the 83 year old former Royal
official is Prince William's godmother
spokesperson for Prince William said
racism has no place in our society and
called the comments unacceptable saying
that it is right that the individual has
stepped aside with immediate effect
eyewitness Mandu Reid who is leader of
the women's equality party told BBC news
that she found the comments by hussy to
be offensive racist and unwelcoming she
also recalled having a sense of
incredulity upon hearing the question
quote we we take this incident extremely
seriously and have investigated
immediately to establish the full
details that's the statement from the
Buckingham Palace
statement continued in this instance
unacceptable and deeply regrettable
comments have been made we have reached
out to ngozi Fulani on this matter and
are inviting her to discuss all elements
of her experience in person if she
wishes in the meantime the individual
concerned would like to express her
profound apologies for the hurt caused
and has stepped aside from her honorary
role with the with immediate effect all
members of the household are being
reminded of the diversity and
inclusivity policies which they are
required to uphold at all times
okay so this uh official Susan Hussey 83
years old
just
immediately thrown under the bus by
everybody around her like everyone
around her
throwing her under the bus
83 years old
including people that you know have
known her uh for for decades right under
the bus
because because she asked a black woman
where she's from
and of course this is being a condemned
across the board in the media you know
by the media in the UK and here in the
states and this all began with a Twitter
post this is how this all got out here
Twitter post where ngazi Fulani gives
her version of The Exchange and remember
this is her version
so she tweeted this uh from her account
sister space
mixed feelings about yesterday's visit
to Buckingham Palace 10 minutes after
arriving a member of Staff lady sh
approached me moved my hair to see my
name badge the conversation below took
place the rest of the event is a blur
that's a blur because she was so
traumatized so traumatized by it
um and then well here's the thing now
this this again this is
her version of this is This Woman's
version of this Exchange
so lady sh says where are you from
Sister space no where do you come from
We're based in Hackney no what part of
Africa are you from I don't know they
didn't leave any records well you must
know where you're from I spent time in
France where are you from here UK no but
what nationality are you I am born Here
I Am British no but where do you really
come from where do you where do your
people come from my people lady what is
this she says oh I can see I'm going to
have a challenge getting you to say
where you're from where did you come
when did you first come here lady I am a
British national my parents came here in
the 50s
oh I knew we we'd get there in the end
your Caribbean no lady I am of African
Heritage Caribbean descent and British
nationality
okay
that's her that's her that is her
transcripted right version of what
happened there's absolutely no reason to
trust that it's 100 accurate even if it
was an honest person like if you're if
you're after the fact writing out a
lengthy exchange like this it's not
going to be 100 accurate even if you're
honest
which by all accounts this woman is not
and so that's that's her version making
um Susan Hussey look as bad as possible
and yet
she still looks perfectly fine to me
even in fulani's version she Fulani
comes off as Petty and ridiculous you
know what she's trying to ask you okay
where are you what what's uh
where are you originally from what's
your ancestry
like that's what she's trying to get to
you know that
and yet she's being difficult about it
well I don't know what you mean what do
you mean I'm from here I'm from like
what do you mean most recently oh it
just came from McDonald's what are you
talking about
um and now now uh but she says she was
in fact she's gone to the media Fulani
has and said that this was traumatic she
is traumatized by it the whole rest of
the event is a blur she barely even
remembers that she's been walking around
in a daze because of this
here she is on British media talking
about let's watch a little bit of this
clip
tell me how you feel about the palace
saying you've you know they've they've
asked if you wish to come and talk it
through it nobody from the palace has
spoken to me I don't know what what
anyone's talking about I I have not been
in communication direct communication
unless they've spoken to somebody from
Sister space like a member of staff I
personally have had no conversation with
anybody
from the palace I don't know about an
invitation well let me read this out so
people know we have this is from the
palace statement we have reached out to
ngoji falani on this matter and are
inviting her to discuss all elements of
her experience in person if she wishes
right I mean
um like I said I'm about positive
solution this is 16 days of activism and
I am not going to contradict what we're
about a sister space okay so of course I
would be happy to have shut up
uh
oh I'm I'm I I want to find a solution a
solution to what that someone asked you
where you're from what kind of solution
what's the solution
and why would anyone read someone needs
to reach out to me about this for what
apparently you can't be spoken to
without collapsing into uh into a puddle
of Tears so maybe they shouldn't maybe
it's just better if they don't reach out
to you
we should mention by the way this woman
ngozi is apparently originally named
Marlene
so the name is changed to in gozi from
Marlene
and she's an activist apparently funded
by BLM no surprise there
and let's put this up again here's can
we go back to the picture of her of this
woman
now the picture of her in the outfit
oh there it is okay that's what she wore
to the event so
she goes out of her way to appear as
someone from Another Place Another
culture and if you ask her about it
you're racist so it's a trap it's a it
is a setup that that's all this is It's
it it's it's very clear that she went
into this waiting for someone to ask her
where she's from so that she could then
accuse them of racism that's all it ever
is with these race Hustlers everything's
a trap everything's a setup
and it's all built around this
ridiculous Trope that somehow it's
racist ask a non-white person where
they're from because we have to specify
non-wipers so obviously if you're a
white person and someone asks you where
you're from you know you're not allowed
to be offended by that if you're a white
person and you go to a predominantly
non-white country and people ask you
where you're from it would and you were
offended by it nobody would take your
offense seriously especially imagine if
you're a white person
in a predominantly non-white country
and you go to an official event wearing
some kind of traditional garb like like
an Amish beard with the you know the hat
and the suspenders or a Scottish kilt or
something some sort of cultural Garb
um that is you know associated with with
a with a predominantly white culture
and imagine if you wore that and then
you got offended when anyone asked you a
question about it
let's see you're you're some part of
Africa wearing a Scottish kilt and
someone comes up to you and says well
what's what's that all about where are
you from well how dare you ask me that
what just because I'm wearing this you
would ask me
how dare you it's none of your business
oh please and of course Hollywood has
gotten in on the outrage action the
actor is Ahmed uh posted some kind of
Slam poetry that he wrote about this
subject and I don't know if he wrote
this because of you know for this woman
or if he had written it before but
um anyway this is what he posted in
support of this poor traumatized woman
she would ask me where you're from
like yeah but where you really from
the question seems simple but the answer
is kind of long
see I could tell him when Billy but I
don't think that's what they want but I
don't want to tell them more because
anything I say is wrong
no not anything you say is wrong just
say where you're from that's it just
answer the damn question
jeez
you know people ask where you're from
because they're interested in you and
these race Hustlers they're always
claiming that they're being erased and
they're being marginalized I guarantee
you this in gozi fraud if if rather than
asking if nobody had asked her where
she's from if no one had brought it up
then she would be saying I'm being
erased I'm being authorized
no one's interested in me
so it's a game it's a setup as I said
these people they just set up booby
traps everywhere they go
everywhere they go there's booby traps
all over the place and they're just
waiting for you to fall into it because
they're such disingenuous
Scavenging little vultures
and the appropriate response to someone
like gozi Fulani who's I'm traumatized
my feelings hurt good I'm glad
oh you're oh really it hurts that bad
fantastic I don't care your feelings are
meaningless
you manipulative little
fraud
and and by the way if it's not
disingenuous
I'm almost like
uh giving her the benefit of the doubt
just assuming that this that she's not
actually this psychotically
um over emotional and and unstable
and I'm assuming that this is just a
disingenuous game that she's playing to
set traps for someone
but it's not disingenuous
and this is a sincere reaction to being
asked where you're from
well then again that's just psychotic
and and you have to get over it
when someone talks to you
and says something to you
their intentions
are what matter okay you take it in the
spirit that is intended that's what
adults do
so if someone says something to you and
even if it's uh it's like a pet peeve or
whatever something we all have pet
peeves we all have things that people
might say or do that it's it's
unreasonable for us to be annoyed and
yet we are what a pet peeve is so at
best this is a pet peeve someone asks
you where you're from and it makes you
really upset it's a pet peeve okay it's
your pet that's your thing it's
unreasonable it's not it's not a
reasonable response there's nothing
wrong with someone asking it but you get
annoyed by a fine that's your problem
though that's not anyone else's problem
you have to deal with that that's your
issue
and as a as a as a mature adult
in a social situation your job is to
understand the intent
and to take it in the spirit that's in
intended
but what they've set up on the left here
is this game where well intention
doesn't matter
so when when the speaker says something
their own reason for speaking doesn't
matter all that matters are the feelings
of the of the The Listener
but it's you can't have human
communication that way
human communication only works
if
you know
you're interested in the intent behind
what's being said
of course it's the same game that the
alphabet Club plays you know the
alphabet people that people address in
these androgynous confused ways and you
know the purple hair and the piercings
and all that and they they try to look
as confused and confusing as possible
and then if you quote misgender them or
if you ask about their pronouns in a way
they don't like then they can get
offended by it their whole Aura their
whole personality their whole everything
about them is set up to just be a
manipulative trap for everyone around
them
because the only thing they're looking
to get out of any interaction at all is
their own victimization
because victimhood is power
only appropriate response is just to
dismiss these people utterly dismiss
them with contempt
all right
reporting the Atlantic about the real
Ron DeSantis
um a bunch of never Trump guys like Rick
Wilson have contributed to this report
this hit piece we're reading some of it
it says he was standoffish in general
the Virginia Republican Barbara Comstock
a former house colleague of DeSantis
told me
a strange no eye contact Oddball Rick
Wilson a republican media consultant
wrote on Resolute Square I'd rather have
teeth pulled without anesthetic than be
on a boat with Ron DeSantis says Max
stippanovich a Tallahassee lobbyist who
set sail from the GOP over his revulsion
for Trump and his knockoffs to sum up
DeSantis is not a fun convivial dude he
prefers to keep his earbuds in his step
away from the vehicle Vibes are strong I
think he is going to run into some
challenges Carlos kurbella a former
Republican congressman from Florida who
served with the Santos in the house told
me it's that question that often comes
up in politics the question of would you
want to have a beer with him this is a
big time cliche of course but it does
feel pertinent will he grow on voters
like a catchy song or like mold DeSantis
has his robotic quality that he has to
shed corbello says everything else
checks the Box he's smart and competent
and committed to his ideology he just
has to humanize himself so that's the
whole uh uh Atlantic hit piece it all
revolves around this idea
that Ron DeSantis isn't Fun he isn't a
fun guy to be around and uh he isn't uh
you wouldn't want to have a beer with
him or hang out with him on a boat
and to that I say
um
good
okay fantastic
I I don't I don't need fun politicians
okay I don't need I don't need I don't
need that in fact I've had quite enough
of that like fun is not what we need I
don't need to feel if you're if you're a
politician
and I'm deciding whether or not I
support you
um
I don't need to feel like I could be
your friend I don't need you to be my
friend and if you're running for
president I don't need you to be my
friend I don't need to feel like I'm the
friend of the president because I'm not
and this whole thing and they're right
it is a cliche this I want you would you
sit down have a beer with him who gives
a damn if you'd sit down have a beer
with them
I would want to sit down and have a beer
with any politician
these are like the most boring people on
the planet I mean there are a few
exceptions
but for the most part I don't have a
beer with any of these people
so what that's not what I need I just
need you to be a leader I need you to
know how to get things done
that's all that matters
and look as we get into 2024 the only
here the things that I care about and
this is it
first thing I care about is are you a
winner can you win that's the first
thing because we can't get past Nothing
Else Matters we can't win all the rest
of it is irrelevant so the first thing
the first thing I'm thinking is can you
win
are you a winner and then if you are
the next thing that matters to me is uh
can you lead can you govern can you
accomplish things do you have the
discipline and the competence to
accomplish things and the follow-through
that's what I care about
and you could be in real life the
nastiest son of a [ __ ] while you're
doing that I don't care nobody cares
doesn't matter
I I you know maybe to bring us back a
little bit to the opening monologue I
would love to get away from this like
Cult of Personality all that you know
latching on to people falling in love
with them
I don't need that
Rhonda Sanders I don't have any personal
I don't I don't see him as a friend I
don't know him I don't need to see him
that way
yeah it's no secret that I support him
right now but he could lose my support
and a heartbeat I support him based on
what he's done that's all I care about
I support him based on what he has done
I look at what he's doing and I say I
like these things I'd like for more of
that to happen
but if he stopped
accomplishing things if he started doing
things I didn't support I would drop him
like a bad habit I would drop him
immediately I wouldn't even have to
think about it
that's the relationship we should have
politicians
it's like you work for us okay that's
what it's supposed to be
this term public servant really doesn't
it feels very irrelevant when you look
at the at how things actually work but
in an ideal scenario that's actually
what it's supposed to be you serve us
and so can you get the here's the job
that we need done can you do it or not
if you can't do it get the hell out of
the way
okay you might be a nice guy I don't
care get out of the way
all right let's see you've got a
another video I want to play some of
this another video of a um
trans person
detailing their regrets uh after
transition
and we won't play the whole video we'll
play a little bit of this
[Music]
um
there are a couple things about it that
well we'll just go ahead and play then
we'll talk about it go ahead
I just got diagnosed with vaginal
stenosis if you're confused hi I'm there
I'm transgender and like eight months
ago I got bottom surgery or gender
confirmation surgery so I had a PP and
now I have a vagina and let me just
preface this by saying I do not regret
getting surgery I do not regret it so I
don't want any of y'all conservative
to twist my words I do not regret
surgery however I knew recovery was
going to be hard but nobody tells you
that it could be this
hard but yeah I was diagnosed with
vaginal stenosis and if you don't know
what that is it's basically when Scar
Tissue gets built up inside of the
vaginal Canal to the point where it's
like extremely tight and uncomfortable
and the thing is for the first year
after getting bottom surgery you have to
dilate your vagina religiously because
it's a brand new Canal that needs to be
kept open religiously for the first year
and now that I have the stenosis I I
physically cannot dilate my vagina still
has depth but it's so tight to the point
that it could start to close and form
Pockets that could lead to infection
which means that I have to get another
surgery
quickly just have to get the surgery all
over again and get my vagina replaced
and like it's just so annoying and it
just sucks because my vagina has made me
so happy happier than I've ever been I
finally feel comfortable in my body it's
so pretty on the outside it's just the
inside of it that's all done and now I
have to get an emergency revision
surgery
so
a couple reasons that uh that I think
that's important to to hear as
horrifying as it always is to hear these
stories I mean when you when you hear
like what these surgeries actually what
they're actually doing to people
and this is why I say I mean this this
person
I believe is not a is not a minor I
think it's a technically an adult
does that make this okay though
does that make this okay
is it okay for doctors to do this to
someone
I don't care how old they are
it is just not okay for a doctor to do
that this Frank this grotesque
Frankenstein horror film type stuff
they're doing
and doing it to mentally ill people
every person
who goes to a doctor and wants to have
their penis
flipped inside out and turned into some
approximation of a vaginal Canal every
person who wants that is mentally ill by
definition
and so to actually do it to them
of course that shouldn't it shouldn't be
allowed and yet you know that I I get
pushed back on this from some
conservatives to say well it's one thing
to say that they shouldn't do it but
adults can do what they want
it's not about what this individual can
do it's about what the doctors did to
him
taking advantage of his mental illness
profiting off of it
to just mutilate him in this way
the other thing too is that is that uh
when you hear about uh regret you know
and whatever there are no reliable
numbers uh because no one is really
looking into it and these uh that these
doctors certainly aren't interested in
in cataloging this but they're so there
are no reliable numbers on exactly what
percentage of people regret the surgery
after the fact
but also keep in mind
that for people who don't regret it this
is what not regretting it often sounds
like
it sounds like
he absolutely does regret it okay he's
he's in tears about what's happened to
him and talking about how terrible it is
and yet he says he doesn't regret it
because he's trying to rationalize
because he realizes what he's done to
his body or what's been done to his body
that can never be fully reversed and so
he feels like he just has to live with
it also he doesn't want to contribute to
what he considers transphobia or
whatever
and so many of the people say I don't
regret this is this is what that
actually entails this is this is uh
right
when they say I'm happy with the surgery
that's that's what happy with the
surgery sounds like
and it sounds an awful lot like
someone's who could who wishes they
could do nothing more that they could go
back in time and stop themselves from
going under the knife to begin with
all right
is there is there something a little bit
less I feel like this has been a
relatively angry show even even by my
standards
but that's you know that's that's what
it is
I can't I can't invent what the stories
are to talk about they are what they are
uh this is a little bit less serious
daily wire has this doordash announced
on Wednesday that the food delivery
company will become the latest
technology firm to dismiss a substantial
number of employees in an effort to
limit expenses okay well so it's Mass
layoffs it's not exactly a happy story
either uh the only reason I mention this
is It's always seemed inevitable to me
that doordash and ubereats would
collapse and in some ways you know
um it's it's almost sad that the company
was able to survive this long or ever
exist in the first place not that I want
to see doordash drivers lose their gig
but it's a sad statement about Society
because doordash
can only exist by by charging these
insane delivery charges
so anyone's ordered doordash or breeds
you know how it goes like you order
forty dollars of food and then you end
up paying like Fifty to five dollars or
sixty dollars or something crazy like
that these exorbitant fees
and it's all for the sake of convenience
it's just so that
and I'm guilty of this I'm definitely
guilty of this myself
and I hate myself every time I do it
like I think every single person who
uses doordash ubereats right we all we
hate ourselves when we're doing it you
hit that you hit that final button to
send the order through and you just hate
yourself because you're like why am I
doing this I'm paying like a 25 fee and
I could just get in the car and drive
myself and be back in 13 minutes
and instead I'm wasting all this money
so it's this uh
for the sake of convenience
so you can free yourself up to have more
time to sit on your phone in your house
doing nothing you pay this ridiculous
extreme premium so they're it's like
it's a kind of a test that these
services are running to see to what
extent can you actually profit off of
the laziness of Americans how lazy
they're almost challenging us like how
lazy do you people actually want to be
they keep upping the charges
okay you know what we're gonna charge
you a 100 fee on everything you order
everything you order will be doubled
but you can you can stay sitting on your
ass and we'll we'll bring the food to
you
and what they found is that our our our
laziness knows almost no bounds we we
will pay almost anything
just so that we can remain sitting on
our butts
all right let's get to the comment
sections
[Music]
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
shop the best Brewing gear thermosis
thermoses thermosis thermosis
thermosis is
mugs and apparel designed for folks who
love country and coffee Black Rifle
sources the most exotic roasts from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the U.S by uh by veteran-led
teams of coffee experts stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest
roasts from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Welsh better yet sign your
Secret Santa up for caught the coffee
Club Subscription Service imagine the
joy of a pre-scheduled coffee delivery
all your favorite roasts when you need
them most it's the gift that keeps on
giving so Black Rifle coffee company is
veteran founded and operated they take
pride in serving coffee and culture to
people who love America every purchase
you make with Black Rifle helps support
veterans and first responder causes go
to Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
walls for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel and when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and Americans coffee
okay here's something positive I do have
some good news actually some some great
news uh before we get to the comments
and I
I'll need to tell you about it I'm
trying not to get emotional and process
uh finally The Saga is really and truly
coming to an end uh the drama that has
dragged on for months and months and
which you probably got tired of hearing
about like 15 seconds after I first
raised the issue
that is what is finally coming to an end
the walrus is
coming home uh he is coming home my
sweet walrus
my dear sweet walrus
is coming home where he belongs my wife
has finally caved to the pressure she's
tired of hearing about it also and she
just wants to be she wants to be over
and done with and so uh and and she is
consented therefore to the giant stuffed
walrus being delivered to our home to
its home I should say to its rightful
home and today I'm told it will happen
we cleared out a spot last night in the
living room because that is where this
is going to go because there's nowhere
else to put it it's going to go right in
the living room so that every one of his
stuff our house can see it and we can
have a walrus centered
life okay from from hence forward
um
I don't know we'll all be together as a
family and uh and you know I take great
comfort
and I try to explain this to my wife I
take great comfort also knowing that the
walrus is coming home uh before the
twins are born and what that means is
that the twins will will never know what
it's like to live in a walrusless house
okay they will have they will they will
always have uh the walrus in their lives
and in their hearts and they will never
suffer the kind of deprivations that I
did and I take uh I take great joy in
that as well
a time of great joy
for everyone but my wife
who is deeply
deeply annoyed
and that's okay because she'll come
she'll come to love the walrus I believe
that she will
either that or she'll uh just resent it
and me every time she looks at it could
go either way
but that's a risk I'm willing to take
all right the legs of rolk says with
Matt continuing to dodge the agreement I
can now wholly relate to Jesse Pinkman
when he said he can't keep getting away
with it
so I'm sorry I just want to clarify
watching two animes is dodging the
agreement I agreed to watch one and I
watch two and I've dodged it
I've done double what I was required to
do and that counts as dodging
that doesn't compute
another comment says Walsh you didn't
dance you didn't watch an anime I admire
that
Sven says Matt I thought you should know
uh that I'd be right in the middle of
watching Ben's podcast and without
hesitation switch over to watch yours as
soon as it starts
well I'll I'll take that at least that's
one
one non-anime related comment because as
I'm going through this every other
comment has to do with anime scooter boy
says just watch Death Note man it's an
amazing anime and I'd love to hear your
opinions on the Battle of morality that
takes place
Matt I must unfortunately inform you
that unless these animations you watch
are produced in Japan they cannot be
classified as anime because anime is
just Japanese animation therefore you
will have to ask SBG members in Japan to
produce an anime for you
that's the technicality you're going to
try to get me on
and yeah every comment is about anime
because these are the kind of yeah I
said at the top of the show I like to
focus on uh important subjects
like anime and stuffed walruses
oh here's one Dirk Dykstra says I prefer
Zachariah sitchin's account of ancient
history over Graham Hancock's it's even
more fascinating
yeah I had a couple people we talked
about Graham Hancock on the show a few
days ago and uh I was saying how much I
love alternative
you know sort of alternative history
even if it's outlandish and I don't
really agree with most of it I just I'm
interested in it I find it fascinating
and I had a few people mentioned that I
never heard of this guy
so I looked it up on Wikipedia
um
and it says Wikipedia of course we know
is an is an absolutely trustworthy
Source it says
similar to earlier authors such as
Emmanuel velowski and Eric Von daniken
sitchin advocated a hypotheses in which
extraterrestrial events supposedly
played a significant role in ancient
human history
according to the stitchin's
interpretation of Mesopotamian
iconography iconography and symbolism
outlined in his 1976 book the 12th
Planet there's an Undiscovered Planet
Beyond Neptune that follows a long
elliptical orbit reaching the solar
system roughly every 3 600 years the
planet is called Nibiru Accord I think I
okay I have heard this on Ancient Aliens
before starting to ring a bell according
to sitchin Nibiru collided
catastrophically with Tiamat
which he considers to be another planet
one located between Mars and Jupiter so
now we've got two planets additional
plants we didn't know about this
Collision supposedly formed the planet
Earth
stitching states that when struck by one
of planet nibira's moons Tiamat split in
two
and then on a second pass in the bureau
itself struck the broken fragments and
one half of Tiamat became the asteroid
belt where is he getting any of this
this is is this uh complex in fact he's
going back billions of years into the
ancient history of the solar system and
uh and then there's this race of of
beings and I guess they come to Earth
450 000 years ago and they're mining it
for gold and then us anyway I'm sold I
believe it I'm I'm that's all I need to
read
I think all the evidence is there
and uh it's completely reshaped my
understanding of human history
last Friday you know we launched the
brand new biblical series by Jordan B
Peterson uh this series is called Exodus
and in it Jordan Peterson sits down with
other Scholars to read the book of
Exodus and discuss what it means and why
it remains significant thousands of
years after it was written Scholars at
the table include Dennis Prager uh
Jonathan Pago and many more episodes one
two and three are available to stream
right now and there will be new episodes
releasing weekly trust me you gotta
check out the series here's the trailer
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the Earth
foreign
book is more durable than than Stone
it's more durable than a castle it's
more durable than an Empire
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and God is ethic centered not ethnic
centered well do you want the Pharaoh on
your side or do you want God on your
side that's kind of the question
there's a profound sense here that what
is going on with the Israelites is the
contrast to Pharaoh right like under no
terms where you go and the Israel's had
to say we will go under any terms and
we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny yes exactly I want villains to
get punished but do you want the
villains to learn before they have to
pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
you have to be a member to watch ahead
to dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member and watch Exodus today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it is arguably one of the most important
cases of our time and you probably
haven't even heard about it Business
Insider has the report about a court
decision in France that though it may
have no legal bearing on the United
States still represents a historic win
for the most persecuted group in the
western world and by that I am of course
referring to introverts reading from
Business Insider it says a French court
has ruled that companies
can't fire their workers for failing to
be sufficiently fun which I guess good
news for Rhonda santis as well the
ruling comes after a man referred to as
Mr T was fired from the Paris
consultancy firm cubic Partners in 2015
for refusing to participate in after
work drinks and team building activities
according to the court documents Mr T
joined the firm in February 2011 was
promoted in 2014 but was fired a year
later in March 2015 for professional
incompetence specifically his refusal to
adhere to the company's fun values cubic
Partners also said Mr T was difficult to
work with and a poor listener in a
judgment issue on November November 9th
the court found that because Mr T's lack
of participation in the company's fun
values and critical Behavior were
reasons cited for his dismissal he had
been wrongfully fired by cubic Partners
the Court ruled that Mr T was exercising
his freedom of expression by refusing to
participate in the company social
activities and that performing this
fundamental Freedom could not be a
reason for his dismissal
now
we're going to kind of look over the
fact look past the unfortunate fact that
this man is fighting for his god-given
right to not be fun fighting for his
right to not party
you might say and yet the court has
given him the pseudonym Mr T which is a
very fun nickname so even while
vindicating his right to not be fun they
are still forcing funness on him in a
way that I find frankly disrespectful
be the resume this man does not want to
go to the company parties he does not
want to do the after hours team building
my God can you imagine that team
building while you're on the clock is
horrific
when you're supposed to be home and
they're telling you to come team build
doesn't want to do that he doesn't want
to socialize
he doesn't want to be fun he wants to be
boring damn it he wants to go home and
get away from all these people as is his
natural human right as enshrined by the
Geneva Convention or as it should have
been in tried at any rate and I bring
this up because it is it is a rare
Victory indeed for introverts in Western
culture this is a subject introversion
that's been on my mind over the last
couple of days after Fielding a
particularly disturbing email from a
listener during our members block
segment which you have to be a member to
watch by the way if you're not and the
message came from a woman who was
disappointed with her introverted
husband because he refused to dance with
her now in truth
a reluctance to dance has very little to
do with introversion as I'll explain in
a moment even even so
I support a man's right to not dance as
much as I support his right to not give
in to the social pressure to have fun
with his co-workers
and when it comes to dancing as I
explained to the woman uh some of us are
are born with what I call the dancing
Instinct that is the innate desire to
convulse our bodies in strange and
arbitrary ways as a physical response to
music and some of us are born without
that maladaptive and psychotic
compulsion those without it never feel
comfortable dancing and there's no
amount of social pressure or
guilt-tripping that will change that but
it's a subject of introversion that uh
interests me today in fact I talked
about this once on the show
back in the early days when I was
ranting alone in my car which as it
happens is in many ways the introvert's
ideal format for hosting a podcast and
that show recorded I think like four
years ago went semi-viral on YouTube
just a few months ago for whatever
reason and ever since that I've been
getting messages from my fellow
introverts thanking me for speaking up
in defense
of our community if you can even call it
a community because we're all
anti-social and I figured now's a good
time to revisit the subject and flush
out a few points especially in light of
this um Cortes and we should begin with
the most basic point which is usually
lost in these conversations which is to
Define what an introvert actually is
and here's the important Point introvert
is not a shy person not necessarily
anyway
a shy person is someone who is nervous
or timid in social situations
shy people have social anxiety
introverts can be shy but they need not
be in my case I'm an introvert without
question but I can get up and speak in
front of big crowds of people without
any problem that's not something a shy
person can easily do so I'm not shy
therefore but I am introverted how is
that possible well because put simply an
introvert is someone for whom
socializing is maybe not terrifying but
physically and mentally draining
okay so that's what we we are trying to
explain
an introvert is is most energized by
spending time alone or in much smaller
groups like maybe with their family and
extrovert on the other hand is energized
by busier and louder and more active
social situations
an introvert finds these kinds of social
interactions exhausting while an
extrovert finds them invigorating
somehow
but here's the important point
although the extroverts proclivities are
mysterious to me
I still recognize that it isn't wrong
okay neither personality type is wrong
there are benefits to both introverts
tend to be more observant more
thoughtful better prepared more
self-aware more intuitive
while extroverts tend to be babbling
morons
I'm just kidding of course sort of I
mean extroverts tend to be they're
friendlier they tend to be more
enthusiastic they're more they tend to
be more bold more assertive there's some
crossover here of course
for example I may I may you know not be
an extrovert but I don't feel like I'm
lacking an assertiveness yet as a
general rule these are how the
personality types shake out the problem
is that our culture for all let's talk
about tolerance and diversity actually
has very little tolerance for a
diversity of personality types
we have very little tolerance for that
and in many contexts particularly in the
school system or in professional
environments Etc introverts are looked
at with suspicion
like there's there's again especially in
school system there's one
way to be like there's one personality
type they want you to have and if you
don't have that then it's suspicious
uh and they might even put you on drugs
to fix it
or at the very least they're going to be
constantly berated to open up come out
of your shell talk more the message is
that this way of being this disposition
is somehow incorrect
and but it rarely goes the other way the
extra extroverts are are not encouraged
to be more introverted talkative people
are rarely asked to shut their mouths
for five seconds so the rest of us can
hear something other than their voices
for a change
assumptions are made though about the
introvert
it isn't assumed that he's um you know
it's assumed that he isn't talking
because he's snobbish stuck up
standoffish anxious whatever
it's rarely considered
that he might not be talking simply
because there is nothing he feels like
saying at the moment
that's it just someone says why are you
talking I don't feel like saying
anything right now that's it that's all
right it's I'm not imposing on you
some people are satisfied to think
without verbalizing what they're
thinking
there are people who actually enjoy that
they enjoy thinking
without without having to immediately
funnel all of those uh thoughts out of
their mouths and into the world
and these people are called introverts
and there's nothing wrong with them
I think this discomfort with introverts
is largely driven
by our general discomfort with with just
quietness okay we live in a very loud
culture in every moment of every day is
filled with noise with activity with
communication with just lights and
sounds and blaring screens and hustle
and bustle and everything
they're people who walk around with with
headphones or earbuds in all day so so
they never have to endure a single
moment of silence
now introverts though don't have this
fear of Silence
on the contrary We crave it
that's when we do our best work that's
when we can think and create and hatch
our devious schemes to take over the
world we're not afraid of quiet you know
but the culture is
and so then is afraid of us by extension
and that is why the French Mr T's Court
victory was so important and it's why he
is not canceled today but the
extroverted oppressors
certainly are
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the
aforementioned members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]